if you've won the Tour de France you've
won a lot of really big races what's the
secret to success and don't tell me it's
exercise I think maybe the most highs
another win the Tour de France is win
again and win again I win again fire one
say to you one secret i think that the
second is it enjoy it with with a with
the training on with the work enjoy the
training and work yeah that's the secret
yeah ok and do you enjoy it yeah of
course how many miles did you write last
year 10,000 kilometers ya know i'm more
more maybe i think they close to 30,000
and you enjoyed every mile no but yeah I
enjoy I for example go to training camp
for 20 days out of my home concentrate
them for me is no heart because I need
are concentrated at hundred percent in
the in the bicycle in the in the
objective and I enjoy the day that I
don't enjoy with when my work is the
moment of finish are you going to win
the tour this year the Tour de France i
will i will try non i want by the the
first of the day of the year will be the
giro d'italia yeah i know that if i go
20 maybe it's a risk because you don't
know if you will be at the person in the
tool because it is difficult recovery
well after a bit or prepare for one tour
and then prepare for another tour right
yeah we doing you only have a 33 days
and has no there is nothing maybe the
time that i want your arguably the best
cyclist in the world but if you were in
a different sport you might make much
more money do you ever wish you when you
were little kid decided to go into
football and not cycling nice boys if of
course the hygiene and i believe a one
thing this is a lot of times the people
say how the football players have a baby
country i was respect to the cyclist but
for other party i think that they do
need believe in in do in to work and
don't believe in other words and then my
opinion and cyclist and i'm cycling on
the photo prior the food of pliers and
for me I'm very happy with my situation